now we need the water get nice and hot
yes okay so we can sort of part boil the
chips eighty salt I don't know let's go
every day at home keep up let's go right
potato yes turn on his side okay
yeah now we're gonna make chips we're
gonna cut the potato in half no in half
that's it good yeah wait a minute
good come on Chris no each half all
right quarter okay good
now everybody at home in half and in
half again yes now it's really important
yeah so actually cut these if it cut
evenly they're gonna cook evenly Chris
Moyles
I carried up let's go in half I've got
off again in half then I'll forget show
hey this is Carey we're not slopey cool
I'm doing it let's go kind of did a
quarter sort of hi okay right it's
important hey yeah how'd you get these
things all the same size
therefore they cook evenly yeah and more
importantly they will become nice and
crispy yes yes now right Janet how you
doing giant going in nine fine now let's
be honest I bet you're dying
do you those chips aren't you I hate
[ __ ] [ __ ] Janet Janet you're wearing
the same clothes as me you're trying to
copy me
huh no good Nick is my look and you
copied me rock that's it the best you
can do alright listen Janice three
pensioner thank you so much hey get that
water boiling right chips Chris yeah
going to the water okay you need a touch
more in there like wow just touch more
than there right chips in these two beer
now cut them in half I forgot eligible
for love did look what is that
no I was at our beginning hi-yah each
half into a quarter all right like that
easy
and we keep the skin on okay now we keep
the skin on yeah yes it also makes sure
they don't break up while I'm cooking
right in the pan
come on Craig do it that way I'm not
gonna let you download it well before
they gotta move your hands a little bit
let's go I'm movin essence it's a big
ass tween everybody at home do not be as
slow as chrismole yes
stay with me not him right in okay
that's Escala pan on right on the second
we got a pan on I said oh they got dots
that's it you got to turn the real it's
all inside right that's important right
look at that pan very very hot now
potatoes come up to the boil
yeah at a time three minutes okay